previously on the flaming sea sorry
grumps I give you bulls Ron well it even
feels smudged the president
consciousness has been split across
three alternate dimensions okay shut up
let's go in turn Rachel take a look in
the back here
you need me to drop off your
dry-cleaning sir what no hold on
show some respect for your president
that's our president it looks like a
piñatas large intestine it'll look
better once we stuff his consciousness
back into this empty skin bag Randy
where are we headed first Randy oh sorry
man I was thinking about something else
okay I'm charting the strongest neuro
magnetic ping right now setting
coordinates for the super song fun fun
dimension fine maybe if your idea of fun
is singing karaoke and dancing and
playing video games 24 hours a day oh
yeah no gay it does sound fun but it's
not look at it this way this dimension
is president Brody's carefree joy
unchecked by any creeping sense of his
own mortality in other words a living
nightmare initiating landing sequence
beep boop boop beep brace yourself for a
surprisingly smooth landing
[Music]
beep boop boop the president's neural
ping seems to be originating from the
highest point here what should I do here
keep the president moist pardon me
coming to thank you what the fun
supercede take the go-go music rhythm
challenge do you accept sure yes
Oh No
[Music]
one two cha-cha-cha one two cha-cha-cha
down you go well that didn't go
[Music]
let's level up cool I know right
coming through
[Music]
hey thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great Conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy Japanese pornography